sweet zoom thanks Joe does it have a
cassette deck look at this it's a lovely
piece of hardware is it aerodynamic like
my new ipod nano doesn't it doesn't have
to be because this is never good girl
flying through the air which i believe
is gonna happen with that with that ipod
I think shake to shuffle is going to
what's going to happen is that it's
gonna be like the nintendo wii we get
were throwing gonna you're gonna you're
gonna have a lot of ipod I panasonic's
long and TV margin TVs are lodged in
people's skulls and I think that that's
a bad thing fortunately you can turn it
off you see here I don't have that
problem with my zune you know why no
accelerometer so that's the new zune
this is the newseum did it when to come
out it came out yesterday along with a
software update so the zune software
suite at oh it's got some some new
things on it mix you anyway right what's
an artist that you like you are no no no
no way so you play erlend oye album
cover erlend oye will come up yeah and a
bunch of different artists that zoom
thinks you might be interested in will
sort of roll around that so zoom things
you're interested anything of patsy
cline that's right that's cool that's
cool dads now i actually think it's a
little bit better than the genius I
think the selections are a little bit
more right on tonight I also like the
waist graphic detail yeah i mean the
genius is pretty cool what amazes me is
that even though there's like it takes a
while to set it up you have to upload
your new library at send some data back
down right um it's pretty quick like i
can do it it works for mark would be
fast so i go to like whitest boy alive
for example right choose it there's a
song they're done with you hold down the
center button look at all those genius
playlists that I just our genius
associated song right real quick and
then you can just save it if you want
right I don't but I mean that's just a
list the the nice thing about the mix
view is that I think the selections are
a little bit more right on and I also
like the ways graphically set up I think
it's just it looks nicer can you do it
on your little 2 inch screen there open
up your macbook for example uh no I
wouldn't be opening up my macbook oh why
not because the zune is not mac
compatible
can you squirt music any peace corps
taking at me what one negative on the
new ipod okay i don't like it at all I
don't like the form factor I was really
psyched when they went to what I called
triscuit shaped ipod it's better for
watching videos and it fits in your
fitness gear better shake to shuffle I
guess could be fun if you're into that I
could just push shuffle also works
nicely energy saver plus we gave it a
seven out of ten what do you think of
the new zune if you're somebody who has
a PC and you don't mind squirting your
music all over the place the zune is a
definitely a grand NC say you hate apple
say you're not a fan of gab so you're
not a fan of the airfoil shape then
maybe the zune is right on for you well
I'll ever know I mean I think it gets a
little bit more than that I think that
the zune is good for somebody who likes
to listen to the radio and as a pc if
you're or if you have a lot of friends
who have students that that's not a
realistic scenario but you have a lot of
friends also 900 realistic scenario so
this little guy is the Sylvania G
netbook means 0 and this is one of two
entries that Sylvania now has into the
mini notebook market um Jose Sylvania
don't they make light bulbs yeah they do
well basically what they're trying to do
this is this another company that is all
about starting this new mini notebook
market this is a totally new trend
that's happened in the last twenty to
twelve months so we've had Dell HP and a
bunch of other companies as susko
masseuse as the first that's right as
the first week and that's probably still
the best one wait a minute did you just
say the EPC is the best one in the
market right now yes I'm gonna have to
take exception to that so this is a disk
compact little guy I mean you know about
three pounds right so then you actually
claims that it's just 2.2 pounds but we
found that it's a closer to a little
more than two and a half hours yeah we
really however put it over three like
three over three with robbery yeah which
makes it actually one of the heaviest of
the mini notebooks on paper it looks
pretty good I kind of like the features
that are included with this it's got
three USB ports audio in and out there's
an SD card reader right here yeah and
then
he has no ports in the macbook air it
does yeah that's not hard and then you
open it up and you know the screen is
not bad the keyboard I have to say
they're really trying here but if you're
a touch typist it smells list totally
those small I mean like that a small if
you probably put my hand over and I've
got a large hand but it just completely
overwhelms the keyboard and you really
can't do anything I play with this for a
while there's no shift key over here on
this side that drives me absolutely
bananas let's get to the operating
system is running a bun to linux and I
actually kind of like the interface I
think it's pretty well laid out it's
easy to navigate around the applications
are all pretty accessible kind of like
the style of it we had some problems
early on like we couldn't really boot up
some stuff and we actually put in a
couple of MPEG files and it kind of
messed it up yes I did notice when you
launch applications it's a little bit
slow now to be fair sylvania has said
that they sent us pre production unit
there are some problems with the
operating system and our software that
are going to be fixed yet in a future
version so will revise our review after
we've had a chance to take a look at
that I like it I think we understand the
operating system but it's still not set
up in the same way it's not the same
left hand you know column type area of
windows or the true simplicity of a mac
OS x if you're used to using a Windows
machine or a Mac machine it's definitely
going to be a little more difficult yeah
just the transition because things
aren't in exactly the same place you
know they expect no like you saw like
you have kind of like the rainbow aspect
that all this right here and I think
people are going to try to people who
are used to windows are going to try to
like click out of it and like how you
know right right so it's just not super
simple like it's really supposed to be
now spec wise this is actually pretty
good it's got a 1.6 gigahertz atom
processor yes 80 gig hard drive right
that's great I mean that's pretty beefy
specs for the netbook now let's get to
the part that I don't really like what
is that price uh-huh 450 bucks is that
right four hundred and fifty dollars
which is about way out of line next yeah
I mean that I'm not even going to
consider $150 bit
you